thank you
okay
I got it all right don't worry things
are gonna be just fine let me ask you
class of 2010 how's it feel how's it
feel all right now here's what I'd like
you to do stand up find the person in
the audience who's responsible for all
of this or just think about the person
who's responsible for getting you this
bar look at them and let's give them a
warm round of applause
Dean Scherzer distinguished faculty
proud parents family members friends and
most importantly the class of 2010 thank
you for inviting me to share in this
moment and to join you in celebrating
all of your accomplishments that have
been and most assuredly will be achieved
it's an honor and honor to be back at
Columbia Law School and although it's
something of a miracle that I ever got
into this esteemed school in the first
place during my undergraduate years here
in Morningside Heights I was one of many
students on this campus who felt
strongly about well nearly everything
during my time it was the 1970s during
my senior year several of us took over
one of our concerns that black students
needed a designated space on campus to
gather and we went to the dean's office
in that building
right over there now this B being
Columbia we proceeded to occupied in
that office the target of that sit-in
was Dean Henry Coleman he heard us out
he led us toward common ground and
eventually to a compromise but I'm not
sure that he was very happy about shall
we say his forced captivity in the
ultimate display of puts about however I
still asked Dean Coleman to recommend me
for admission into this law school and
lo and behold he agreed only at Columbia
my friends that's one of the reasons one
of the many reasons why I love this
university to return today as our
nation's Attorney General to the place
where I first studied the law where I
first dreamed of both serving the cause
of justice and our country's Department
of Justice is an extraordinary privilege
I am proud to be part of this
distinguished institution and it is a
part of me and I am grateful to be among
the first to welcome such a talented
group of men and women into Columbia's
law alumni faculty family family well
let's not get ahead of myself family
and today as always I'm just very glad
to be home I was born a few stops away
from here in the Bronx I grew up in
Queens I attended Stuyvesant High School
in Manhattan and then it's here for
Stuyvesant and then I spent seven
exhilarating years here at Columbia it
was across the street that I unraveled
torts and studied for what seemed like
months with professor Reece Palsgraf
versus Long Island Railroad Company I
still don't understand it it was in the
library that I discovered and hated
contracts and grew fond of all-nighters
it was in the legendary professor
Telford Taylor's criminal law class that
my interest in combating crime and my
commitment to the rule of law was
inspired and it was during school
summers that I had the opportunity to
work for the n-double-a-cp on a few of
the seminal discrimination cases of the
day this law school defined me in ways
that I am still realizing and I'm
confident that in 35 years you too will
reflect and also realize that an
important and unexpected ways this
university has influenced your work and
has enriched your life now I've lost of
course the law school has changed since
I was here there are more international
students and offerings there are a dozen
or so journals instead of adjusted to
and what I hear about the construction
of this 200 luxury on-campus dorm rooms
is that true when we were college
students here President Obama and I were
lucky to have hot running water in the
years since I received my diploma I
suppose I've changed too according to an
American Prospect article that was
published earlier this year I and I
quote entered Columbia College in the
fall of 1969 just in time to grow an
afro and participate in some heated
student protests unquote well something
else has changed since 1976 when I was
sitting in your seats watching as Dean
and shazar mentioned then Attorney
General Edward levy
an honorary degree since then something
more consequential than hairstyles and
protest strategies has evolved and that
something is the law over the past three
and a half decades our legal system has
transformed in ways that while easy to
overlook or to take for granted are
critically important consider that when
I first enrolled in this university I
could not vote even though I was 18 I
could however drink it's true now of
course the right to vote is afforded to
every 18 19 and 20 year old or consider
that recently when I became Attorney
General last February there was not a
single line in nearly 225 years of the
United States code that referred
explicitly to gender identity today the
Matthew Shepard and James Byrd Act which
the president's ID into law last year
does just that
finally protecting our nation's gay
lesbian bisexual and transgendered
citizens from vicious hate crimes
those are just two examples in every
field of the law progress is being
pursued and progress is being made this
is our nation's oldest and perhaps
finest tradition since America's
earliest days young dedicated lawyers
have been using their knowledge and
their training to stand up for justice
finding that their education not only
arm them with an ability to change the
law it also provided them with the power
to change the world our best example of
this may be our earliest example the
development of our Constitution that
today it's worth remembering and
mentioning that our Constitution was not
created in a vacuum it was in fact
created to correct flaws in the legal
framework that had been established by
the Articles of Confederation now don't
worry I'm not here to deliver a lecture
on the law I say that you had your fair
share of those and trust me over the
past year
so have I instead I'd like to offer you
just the just the opposite the slight
but significant correction to the
history that many of us grew up studying
the history of how our nation's most
important founding document our
Constitution was established 223 years
ago today May 14th 1787 a motion was
made in Annapolis Maryland
calling every state delegate to
Philadelphia for the Constitutional
Convention that summer as the story goes
the wise old men of the Republic
gathered to draft what would despite its
imperfections become the greatest legal
document in the history of mankind
now these framers rightly believed that
the Constitution would provide a
framework to extend their commitment to
justice and opportunity for all and as
we had been taught it was these elder
statesmen who hoped it would serve as a
shining example for all the world the
only trouble with this story is that it
is not entirely accurate
through some interesting research to
great historians Stanley Elkins and
Columbia's own Erich McKittrick have
provided a fuller picture they have
revealed that rather than being the
product of venerable old sages our
Constitution was act
actually established at the insistence
of and through the advocacy of young
people and specifically young lawyers
those who supported the Constitution the
Federalists were on average at least a
decade younger than their opposition
several leading Federalists were under
35 and more than a few of them were in
their 20s at 44
the oldest Federalist was George
Washington and many of his
contemporaries like Columbia University
alum John J hatched their ideas about a
strong Democratic central government
during their early years spent studying
the law now this history underscore is a
trend that we've seen time and time
again in every chapter of America's
story young people it seems to me are
uniquely qualified to reimagine and in
doing so to reinvigorate the law and the
world many of the great social
advancements in our nation's history
were in no small part the result of
ideas that law school graduates
envisioned and over time implemented
this is evident whether you're looking
at the eradication of slavery the birth
of the women's suffrage movement in the
passage of the 19th amendment or the
passage of the 26th amendment that
ultimately enabled young people to
participate in record numbers in the
2008 presidential election and it is
especially true when you examine the
conception and creation of our civil
rights laws several weeks ago I traveled
to Greensboro North Carolina to
celebrate the 50th anniversary of the
Woolworth lunch counter sit-ins a small
student movement that quickly grew into
a nationwide cause and over time
inspired sweeping positive national
change it motivated several columbia law
students to take part in Freedom Rides
across Mississippi it paved the way for
Martin Luther King's famous march on
Washington in 1963 and it helped to
spread the philosophy of Dyne violent
protests that advanced the civil rights
legislation of the 1960s and I'd argue
eventually led to the election of the
nation's first african-american
president as well as the appointment of
his first african-american Attorney
General
the exceptional commitment and capacity
of young people especially of those
willing to devote their legal skills and
training for the struggle for equal
justice and for opportunity always has
been and will continue to be essential
in moving our nation forward Columbia
Law School has a long tradition of
graduating students unwilling to sit on
the sidelines of history or miss an
opportunity to work toward and fight for
justice take Bella Bella Abzug class of
1947 after graduating from Columbia Law
in her 20s but before becoming one of
the world's leading feminists she took
on civil rights cases in the south or
take Judge Robert Carter class of 1941
the master's thesis that he developed
here eventually defined the
n-double-a-cp legal strategy in
defending the right of freedom of
association under the First Amendment
and I understand one of our other famous
alums Theodore Roosevelt was in such a
rush to make an impact that after his
first year on campus he dropped out to
pursue a life of public service think
about what he might have accomplished if
like you he had stayed here and
graduated now many of you will follow in
this great tradition in fact some of you
already are Brittney Crowe Patrick began
a new law journal that explores the
intersection of race and law
helping to chart the future of this
still burgeoning field justin steel is
fusing his background in urban planning
with his legal education to help
determine the future of land use laws in
a rapidly changing housing environment
and janitress super Wong is helping to
transform immigration and domestic
violence law around the country there
there are countless more examples in
this sea of blue before me Jennifer so
Keller's work on human rights
Sam Sal Ganic so on healthcare M&F on
international reproductive rights each
of these students each of these students
and many others are harnessing the power
of law to serve as an instrument of
change now of course you can do this in
any number of ways and you will for this
is a terrifically accomplished and
diverse class one in three among you is
a minority student you represent almost
every state in more than 50 countries 15
percent of you have already achieved
advanced degrees not only are you
scholars you are also soldiers cancer
survivors artists rock stars religious
leaders entertainers bankers novelist
journalists and public servants no
basketball players and now you are
entering an uncertain world
one burdened by economic recession but
showing signs of recovery you are taking
leave of this campus in an unprecedented
age of challenge an era of new threats
and a time of war yet you must resist
the temptation to feel as though you
have been dealt a bad hand you have not
been dealt a bad hand you have been
given a rare opportunity consider the
many examples throughout history of
people your age with exactly your
training who have improved the course of
our country and strengthened the
structures and rules that govern our
society and then consider how many of
those leaders were trained in the law
quite a few I expect no less of Egypt
whether you are heading to one of the 30
different states or to one of the dozens
of countries represented by your
post-grad jobs already you have secured
impress engulfed impressive government
and public interest positions record
numbers of you are pursuing clerkships
you will soon begin fellowships at
nonprofits and NGOs that are in
desperate need of your counsel you will
provide legal services to indigent
populations and you will despite these
hard times be entering the world's top
law firms whatever your path by any
measure you are already successful but
as much as you care about your own
future success and you should before you
have worked hard for it I urge each of
you to look for ways to serve others and
to strengthen both our justice system
and our commitment to the rule of law
not only do you have the ability you
know how to now have the credibility and
you also have the responsibility a
Columbia responsibility of course you
may be told many times over the next few
years to wait you may be told that your
vision for a better system needs
ripening or worse a reality check but I
say trust your instincts believe in
yourselves follow your own course unless
of course you're one of the two
graduates who are coming to work at the
Department of Justice where you'll be
taking orders from me never question me
whether you eventually lead movements
rule from the bench return to the
classroom run for office advise clients
or defend the accused you are now ready
to define our future you are no longer
just students of the law you are now
stewards of our nation's justice system
I believe the privilege of earning a
Columbia Law degree brings with it an
ongoing responsibility to use your gifts
and training to improve this system and
I hope I can count on each of you to be
partners in the pursuit and
administration of justice however you
decide to serve you may choose to offer
input into how our nation is going to
combat crime protect our national
security strengthen our education system
safeguard the environment environment or
ensure that all Americans have the
opportunity to realize their dreams and
fulfill their potential but you can all
go forward from this place and from this
moment and give meaning to the ideals
that animate our laws you can also
influence these laws in ways that call
our country to aim higher to become
better and to do more for the most
vulnerable among us but before you do I
encourage you to look back to think
about the most exciting vision you've
had for improving our laws and our
society during your time here perhaps
it's something that you're working
toward right now or maybe it's something
that you've never shared well today
write it down and print it on your brain
talk about it with one of your family
members who has supported you or one of
your friends you've come to rely on
though one of the professor's that
you'll never forget then keep this goal
before you at crossroads throughout your
career and your life ask yourself have I
done it yet and just as so many other
Columbia Law School graduates have keep
asking this question even when your hair
has turned gray even after your afro is
long gone keep asking until your answer
is yes this afternoon as we celebrate
all that you've achieved I am eager to
see where each of you will lead our
nation and our world but wherever it is
know this we are counting on you
I am counting on you your nation is
counting on you and starting now history
is counting on you good luck and
congratulations I am proud of you all